beginning of kimming the back break fall
back prank call is one of the most
essential techniques you're going to
need to learn in aikido you're going to
use the bright correct fall over and
over and over it's important to
understand when you're falling we're not
following like a tree in the woods we're
lowering and curving ourselves as much
as possible this lessens the impact
we're going to have with the ground
so for example when i fall i wouldn't
fall like this
one of the problems with that is the
part that's going to take the greatest
impact is going to be at the end of the
lever right now the end of the lever is
my head i don't want my head to get
smashed so anytime i feel myself falling
i'm going to lower myself
now notice when i lowered myself i also
practiced the rocking motion where i
curve my spine and tucked my chin this
enabled me to keep my head from hitting
the ground and my back from taking any
impact as i fall backwards i'm going to
lower myself onto my butt it's big it
can take a lot of impact so as i roll
back i'll curve my spine tuck my chin
and i won't take so much force from the
ground
if we add slapping to it we force two
more good habits one good habit is
slapping spreads out the surface area of
my body so it means i take a little less
impact for each part another good part
of slapping is it requires me not to put
my hand back i absolutely want to get
out of the habit of landing on my hand
like this it's horrible for my joints my
shoulder my elbow and my wrist joint
will all take a lot of impact it can be
super bad for me if every time i go
backwards i slap i'm training myself not
to put my hands down but instead to
bring my hands up and back
the back breakfall i'm christopher hunt
thanks for watching
you